Hollywood has officially released another
big budget Robin Hood story, and you probably
didn't see it.
What happened to make this reimagining stray
so far from the target?
And what could have been done differently?
Let's break down the real reasons Robin Hood
bombed at the box office.
"Please tell me you got that."
Robin Hood attempted to revive a classic folk
tale with style and flair.
With a cast including Taron Egerton, Jamie
Foxx, and Jamie Dornan, the movie tries to
tell a dark and gritty origin story along
the lines of Batman Begins.
The movie's modern approach includes over
the top combat scenes, with automatic crossbows,
explosions, and super-stylish archery.
Robin Hood himself is given a personality
upgrade, too.
The outlaw has long been understood to be
a champion of the commoner, but now he's a
class-war-leading revolutionary with a puzzling
modern wardrobe.
"This is a departure from your father's Robin
Hood.
This one has a dope twist to it."
But all of these appeals to modern tastes
totally missed the mark with audiences, leaving
the movie falling flat on its face over the
long Thanksgiving weekend.
No matter how you look at it, Robin Hood was
off to a disastrous start, only claiming the
number seven spot at the domestic box office
in its first weekend of release.
In the United States, it brought in just over
$14 million against a budget of reportedly
close to $100 million.
With the movie having debuted on over 2,700
screens, that would seem to suggest a lot
of empty theaters.
Things seem equally dismal for Robin Hood
outside of the US, with the movie only bringing
in around $8.7 million from foreign markets.
The performance made for total earnings of
about $23 million after the movie's first
weekend, enough for some commenters to call
it one of the biggest bombs of the year.
Making things worse, that $100 million production
budget only covers costs before marketing,
meaning the movie is likely way more in the
red than the public will ever get to know.
It's stunning how much money was sunk into
this movie since, despite all of its name
recognition, it was never a sure thing.
"It's too dangerous"
"Ah but the danger's what makes it fun"
Though the 2018 Robin Hood movie was marketed
with the tagline "The legend you know, the
story you don't," that's little more than
wishful thinking.
This story is extremely well-known.
The Robin Hood folktale has been told on film
literally dozens of times, to the point where
even the most disengaged person could rattle
off the story's basics.
"Robin Hood has a green hat, a bow and arrow,
and a loyal crew.
He robs from the rich and gives to the poor.
There's a friar named Tuck, a maid named Marian,
and a John who is little.
They're all foxes."
You get the idea.
How does a studio generate excitement for
a story that's been done to death over 700
years?
It's a good question, and one this movie clearly
failed to crack.
Robin Hood's lukewarm reception can partially
be attributed to a lack of interesting star
power.
Director Otto Bathurst reportedly waited a
year for lead actor Taron Egerton to become
available for this reimagining, being determined
to see him in the role.
But why?
He explained his decision to the Courier Mail,
saying,
"I wanted to find someone who was accessible
and who seemed real, and Taron is that guy.
He is incredibly charismatic and charming,
but he also has serious intensity."
"Taron's got a really fantastic kind of 'everyman'
about him.
Serving up the emotional drama and then also
the fun"
Despite a relatively solid critical track
record, Egerton has never proven himself to
be a huge draw in a lead role, at least outside
of the success of the star-studded Kingsman
movies.
Despite technically being the protagonist
of that series, Egerton's role has generally
been but one small part of a more famous ensemble.
Even with a capable assist from Jamie Foxx
and others, it's possible that this cast just
wasn't enough of a draw for the well-worn
material.
If Robin Hood had come out during a barren
weekend in January, it might have stood a
chance.
Instead, it made its debut during one of the
most packed release windows of the whole year,
and got trampled.
Coming in at number one over the long Thanksgiving
weekend was Ralph Breaks the Internet, the
Wreck-It Ralph sequel that stomped its competition
with the second-best Thanksgiving opening
ever.
The movie also debuted below Creed II, The
Grinch, Fantastic Beasts 2, and Bohemian Rhapsody.
It even performed worse than the modestly-budgeted
Mark Wahlberg comedy Instant Family, which
was holding onto sixth place in its second
week during Robin Hood's rollout.
Apparently, all six of these movies are more
compelling options for holiday moviegoers,
once again suggesting that audiences really
don't care about the Robin Hood story anymore.
All of these factors could have been overcome
if Robin Hood had turned out to be an awesome
movie.
But it unfortunately debuted to a dismal reception
from critics and audiences alike.
Rotten Tomatoes, counting roughly 100 reviews,
initially tallied a 13% approval rating for
the movie, marking it one of the worst-received
adaptations of the Robin Hood story yet.
It also got a middling B Cinemascore, which
tends not to translate into positive word
of mouth.
On the other hand, between its weird costumes
and other strange anachronisms, there's a
lot about Robin Hood that audiences have found
amusing.
Richard Roeper, writing for the Chicago Sun-Times,
even said that the film is "legitimately funny."
It has the makings of a movie that's so off-base
and over-the-top that it actually becomes
good.
But that kind of reputation usually isn't
enough to make the hundred million dollars
this movie desperately needs.
While Robin Hood may have enough of a spark
of madness to be kind of entertaining, it
doesn't seem to be working on audiences in
the way its producers intended.
Despite ending with a sequel tease, it seems
doubtful at this point that the tale will
continue.
Hopefully the next people who try and make
a movie out of Robin Hood take the hint.
We know this story already.
Maybe it's just time for something new.